all right uh let's move on what you need
to know on this monday morning begins in
but in many ways will be the epicenter
of the lingering offseason in the nfl
green bay what happens with what matt
before called the audible thing the
freedom that aaron rodgers has or
doesn't have at the line of scrimmage
hall of fame quarterback brett favre
chimed in this weekend he was back in
wisconsin for a golf tournament and he
essentially said look
let aaron rodgers play his game let him
do his thing
let him play his game and don't disturb
that very much now i don't know whether
farv means from the moment he gets the
ball in his hands you know the things he
can do with a football or is he talking
about giving him full freedom at the
line of scrimmage to change the play
anyway he sees fit that's going to
continue to be the pressure point for
the green bay packers how much
discretion should he have will he have
and ultimately will he exercise even if
he isn't authorized to do so at the line
of scrimmage i don't know where that's
going to come down chris and we wouldn't
be talking about it if both aaron
rodgers and matt lafleur hadn't decided
to talk publicly about it or at least
talk about it to a reporter who told a
story that is has been for a week now
something that has has continued to be a
talking point because nobody knows how
this is going to play out and it's
something everybody's going to be paying
attention to when the packers get
together for training camp yeah well
aaron rodgers in that green bay offense
the last few years has such has such
free reign i mean it was almost getting
towards the you know peyton
manning-esque type of like quarterback
play style as far as every play was
doing something at the line of scrimmage
changing this changing that whatever it
may be they're gonna have to find that
balance you and i talked about that i
think what brett favre is saying is hey
aaron rodgers of course is great and you
got to let him do a lot of the things
that uh he has always done and and of
course has been extremely successful
with moving the ball making big plays in
the pass game whatever that is so i
think that's the aspect farv is talking
about i don't know if he necessarily
means every play it's the same way it
used to be i mean
in my perfect picture i look at it like
this lefleur they run his offense they
stick with that for the meat and
potatoes of the offense but then they
have certain plays or situations where
rogers is giving free reign to if uh if
he sees a certain blitz or sees a
certain coverage where they've discussed
during the week then rogers can get out
of it because they know they got the
defense in a tough spot to where they
can really take advantage of one of his
audibles i mean roughly that's going to
come what it comes down to at the end of
the day and where they can get that
ironed out for that fine line of what's
acceptable and what's changing the play
too much and really kind of ruining the
flow of the offense as matt lafleur sees
it
and here's what's odd to me chris right
when they hired matt leflore they knew
what kind of an offense he was going to
run or they knew or should have known
god knows how many questions were
actually asked about it but you would
think that it's a fairly important item
for interviewing any head coach who's
going to be working with aaron rodgers
how much freedom does he have at the
line of scrimmage to change the play you
i i look i i'm no football executive but
i'd like to think if i was interviewing
potential candidates to replace mike
mccarthy i would have a bunch of
questions about how this is actually
going to work so here's where i'm
concerned they knew or should have known
from the moment leflore was hired that
this was going to be a potential issue
they're on the back end of the off
season program it's over and it's still
not resolved they've had weeks to work
together they've had weeks to work this
out and it feels like it's just an issue
they just identified two weeks ago like
oh yeah by the way we got to work out
this audible thing you work it out in
the off season so when training camp
opens you know what you're going to do
you know what your plan is you don't
just wing it in the preseason and figure
it out rogers hardly plays in the
pre-season yeah no i'm just i i think
this is something that that look i i'm
okay it's an issue fine but i think it's
an issue that should be resolved that
isn't something that should be hanging
over the packers as training camp
approaches well the encouraging thing to
me is that they're having the
conversation i mean mike silver we know
he went to cal he's got some corn
some sort of connection with aaron
rodgers right and the fact that lefleur
talked about it so openly and rogers
talked about it so openly that to me
tells me that it's it's a work in
progress and going in the right
direction
you're not going to have everything like
ironed out this time of the year quite
yet mike i mean yes i mean to a degree
you want to be able to go into training
camp and go okay this is the direction
we're going and i feel like that's where
we are with them like i said i just
think they got to figure out that fine
line of when's too much when's okay this
is go ahead aaron rodgers get us in the
right play and i think that's what
they're talking about and tinkering with
and trying to figure that out and i
think they will find that out and figure
out how to package certain plays and
formations to where rogers knows okay in
this formation i can get to these few
audibles
the coach has given me the green light
here to do that in this formation with
this personnel set and i think
eventually they will get there they're
just kind of
a dialogue that's continuing
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports